all right well good stuff mom busy
yeah better than the alternative yeah
van man Jimmy cricket Jiminy Cricket
please
ready we just really need to think about
what we're doing from our pitch deck and
our website I'd like to make those
decisions now so that we're in a good
place for you know December 1 Jeff how
are you my friend
Ohio life right so let's listen it's
really nice to connect i I've been
keeping tabs through Peter it's a it
sounds like things are going well and
I'm happy I know you're super busy so I
wanted to grab two minutes to a say
hello and B and B I am we've been doing
a social digital audit product here at
Vayner that's been going extremely well
and and I wanted to make some curveballs
to it so I did a few things on spec to
teach my ninja team that I put on it how
I want it done and one of the brands I
asked them to do it on was just just
because I was I knew you were there
and by the way I'm super aware in all
this but I'm I'm playing long game with
our relationship so beep I wanted to
send that over to you with with the
context of I wanted you to see it
because I think it's valuable insight
and I want you to use it with whoever
you're working with I'm not worried
about getting business this time I'm
worried about staying in your circle
because I believe in you and so I was
going to do the spec work anyway
so I figured I might as well do it on
three or four brands that were
relationships outside my current roster
so I put so we have something pretty
cool I think you'll enjoy it I'm going
to send it to you feel free if you want
any clarification you can call me
directly I mean we we've been having
some crazy results with with um with up
like real stuff if you find yourself in
New York stop by I'm thrilled to show
you under the hood you know we are I
mean just black and white like if you
want to sell for
Albertson's you can prove it it's just
everybody's more reliant on Nielsen's
and modeling mixes internally than
actual depletion reports our mmm says
we're losing and our sales are through
the roof because we're running Facebook
as TV commercials and the mmm doesn't
recognize it the end I'm willing to give
a lot because I have a much bigger I
have a much bigger plan than your
current role so we'll talk soon I'll
send that over take your min videos see
if they care about anything thank you
morning
hello how are you that also please
should I speak Spanish if you want to I
can't I can all right
aha the neck alone I was young anyway so
I think the biggest thing that every
immigrant watching this and every person
but obviously being an immigrant I have
those feelings for that audience is
you've already won
see that's what people don't understand
you've already won let me explain
picking the right business having the
right talent to see where the world's
going
there's intuition there's nothing I can
say to make you do that there's talent
there's timing
there's luck that's real so I'm not
worried about that you know why I'm not
a good role of that nor are they I'll
tell you what they are in control of the
reason they've already won and they're
just willing to work much harder than
the people that live in the place that
they were born when you were born in
America when you were born in love in
the UK when you were born in Canada when
you're born in these places that have
stability of democracy for a long period
of time you're softer I don't know
I'm willing to go work picking up
garbage right now yeah right now it just
doesn't seem so crazy to me you know I
just did it I've done it I don't know
what else to say you know when you
realize you go to a land of opportunity
when you leave in as well II I don't
give a [ __ ] if you were an engineer a
doctor you know the the wealthiest car
dealership when you've lived through one
two three five seven nine years of
dictatorship communism socialism at
scale and you get to leave somehow and
go to a place of capitalism you're
willing to wash dishes you're willing to
drive a taxi you just are cuz you're so
grateful for the opportunity that is
right that's it
totally and so and so the things I
normally preach patience immigrants have
that immigrants come and
their patient is [ __ ] you know they live
in shitty apartments they don't buy nice
things they eat minimally and they save
and they save and they save and so you
know I think especially the current
economic political climate in America
where there is a big group of people
pushing against immigrants
I understand how an immigrant can get
down can get worried can get concerned
can get bummed out I give them the
recommendation that uh that I live with
which is put your head down work and
everything has a funny way of working
itself out and remember that you've got
it better if you're complaining about
immigrants you've already lost to
immigrants alright my friend thank you
so nice to me
yeah because there might not be one how
are you are you can travel with uh with
uh tripods Oh holiness bonafide catch a
minute sir let's go get over it's
awesome how are you ah good it's a real
pleasure yes obviously finally meet you
how long did how long have you been with
webbing uh nine months sorry it took so
long Quinn do you feel do you feel like
you have the outlet to come and speak to
Claude me or or Aaron or Dylan or Jason
or does that feel like ooh that's like a
big to go up there to ask for that maybe
an appropriate or too big of an ask it's
a big ask I don't want to talk to Jason
or Dylan I think you should and I think
you should say that I told you to do it
okay use me as your air cover okay and
talk to Claude too like when I have
those company meetings or send those
emails I mean it yeah I know nobody
believes me because I wanna bother you
but I mean it yeah like what's supposed
to happen otherwise nothing all right
and it's and you have to act on it with
grace and respect you can't walk into
Jason be like you put me on this now or
[ __ ] you that's not gonna work
no but even knowing that that's what
you're thinking
creates opportunity even you sleep you
didn't have to say it to me now and if
you didn't nothing would happen now
you're going to say it to Claude
you're going to say it to Jason you're
gonna say that I told you to do that
which then creates you all the air cover
and then maybe something will happen oh
I hope so too yeah but if nothing else
now you know just keeping it inside then
you don't even know right
until I hear yourself saying I'm like
yeah you know I actually do want that
yeah again as long as you do it with
grace and respect there's nothing wrong
with asking demanding is very different
than asking absolutely
thanks man
yes for me to share with as you know
it's been a tough summer for me July was
pretty much a career-low point
it's taught me my tracks
I didn't reflect on myself I mentioned
it probe yep leadership approach yep
skills and I spent weeks identifying
areas weakness places I can improve what
I can do to make sure yep I'm bringing
your vision yep
give me some coach I have modeled how he
was interacting with folks I looked back
at my 18 months and I'd fi the fact that
like I was really manager first not
leader coach I was just trying to keep
it together I get it and I'm and listen
circumstance and styles make fights to
the best boxers in the world get in the
ring you're sleeping by the fifth round
because they both have a similar
defensive style and it's not an
interesting fight you know there are
leaders in this company who've walked
into fluff situations where all the air
covers been created by me everything's
[ __ ] rosy you walked in you know your
timing in those 18 but you guys had a
lot of things to deal with so look I
think there were I you know I didn't
stop you the other day and give you
those like I watch a lot but I think
you'd you know I'm so excited by the
tone of your conversation that I want to
equally throw back at you as like sure
there's look like we can all do things
better you have an interesting
circumstance you know there's a lot to
do there you also have a partner who's
creative so you took on the stress of
everything I saw that like a man like
work in 2015 didn't work yes and also
and also like it could work forever but
the things that it does to the
personality of the person that has to do
that part runs the gamut not to mention
I forget nothing
I remember soccer practice talk so like
I'm you know I'm apathetic there's a
reason you didn't get fired keep going
so you know I want you to know I listen
to the feedback I took it very seriously
I know better than that because you've
acted on it yeah you can't you can't act
on something you didn't hear so it's
going really well right
are you like pumped doesn't it feel good
to well I'm super aware one when I look
back at my own management training I
don't know have yeah I was a thing yeah
really it's a production guy I was show
running I had teams for a tight amount
of time I sent one away I know I know so
much of this talk to me about the part
I'm interested in so tell her before
that how does it feel to like look at
the peeps and the way they look at you
now yeah feels good also because I'm
more focused yeah I'm caring about three
of everything you've cared about
everything now I want to know who these
people are whatever you can't you care
about everything now
and I have enough people scaling me now
that I don't have to do it for everybody
yep that I got two line producers no one
else happens you know what else happen
to you happens everybody with that scale
you start learning that people are
capable of doing things too and if not
you're even better off letting them fail
that's a big thing I mean I don't you
know this I don't Mack micromanage [ __ ]
biggest complaint of all you've seen if
it was like am I even here like you know
what I mean that's a huge value prop and
that happens at a scale growth - you
can't do everything sometimes yeah so
it's good nano I wanted to know that I
intended early back the truck by the way
that little Winky Winky I gave you was
massive acknowledgment of that um by the
way I genuinely believe my trust was
waning but I don't know we we fire a lot
of people wouldn't trust it like it like
to meet trusses interesting it's like it
cut it's very binary either I have it or
I don't
so truth is I kind of always had it I
wasn't pumped as much as I am right now
about it right now I'm very confident
especially because you have a big
advantage over a lot of other people
you've tasted both sides of it now my
biggest like I have more confidence in
you now than 90% of the org
it was feeling the thin ice all summer
yeah I'm sure you weren't I know I was a
burden I didn't want we're a burden
listen you know listen here's the good
news here's the good news I appreciate
that but you know what we all went to
bat we were all fighting for it you're
fighting for it think about how cool
that is we were fighting for it to work
that's what nobody gets like that gets
me so mad only thing I do is to fight to
make it work the amount of money time
and energy that this company deploys to
have this conversation is through the
roof and the sad part is I only get to
have one of these for every four you
know all the others is wasted time and
money and energy right but this is so
valuable yeah
now I'd appreciate it I'm looking
forward to this moment I have one with
Claude James I want you guys to know
that I'm very focused
but the whole thing is going very well
it's top of mind my energy people know
it dude the [ __ ] way they feel about
you is fundamentally different good I'm
glad that's coming through it's real
yeah I mean my 2015 was it was very like
results-driven I get it though this
practice I get it this year it's about
like and you were tricking out of a
firehose there's a million batteries I
don't care about the people that are
here that I got I knew I could I really
genuinely thought they are and thing was
gonna work out I thought he would bring
you value yeah and we were close before
I know which is why I was constantly
with my boss but now it's different it's
a different thing because I also know
that you ow soft understand he was also
molded in a different way here he you
know it wasn't that he's better
different he just had the benefit of
kind of goat think about what you're
gonna do for everybody now he just had
the benefit of going through it yeah you
know maybe didn't have the same
narrative that's almost really
irrelevant yeah so now we have some new
hires get more creative producers yep
I'm spending more most of my time with
them yep because structurally yeah we're
a little stronger yet Ross yep and I
want them to have a good experience
every day
positive and when I give critical
feedback I want you to know that I'm
also like honey aren't you get on both
sides
honey Empire right reinforce honey
Empire duty great job honey Empire your
work honey Empire and I'm seeing the
results last year was like surgical
strikes and that it wasn't working for
them doesn't work it's not how humans
work it's good for you'd be a great
engineer you understand
thank you I'm super pumped this was
super funny yeah um so you guys see and
keep hearing good things about me I
believe that I believe that we're back
from it I love it if you could spend
some time with us you it's a very big
conversation here okay cool very big
maybe we can do it
Town Hall thing it's a very big deal
because it's a it's a problem and now
I'm going away for for this TV show it's
uh it's a top two stress in my life but
I also had to like work on the meeting
we're about to have legs like I've got a
I've got some ideas of also what I want
that to be and how I want to be which
you'll be working with me on we have
Skype probably in november/december all
good stuff um the answer is yes I'm
gonna try to sneak one in before the end
of the year and then I'm going to be
there every month I think you want to
they have to know do they want to hear
they half don't like oh no no it's a
real thing it's a real thing all right
go talk to you soon thank you so much
that was a lot of fun Oh
music entertainment my previous job was
with Diddy come where um Alex loved
meeting with you and all he kept like
back sho he's like you've got Joey's
like you're gonna love this
like when I first came here I was a
little nervous on because I came from
take off yes yes
just seeing everything's like tighten it
here but cuz I fall into place
yep I was able to be myself because I'm
not the one to be like not prima proper
or coming from like I be cool right he's
kid but I came in from like a strong
background of just dealing with hands-on
what you're doing yeah learning from
doing a me waiting me too
and I think the thing that I think
you've probably already learned is if
you're good enough I don't care if
you've been here for 40 years I don't
care if you're my cousin I don't care if
you are a Patriots fan which I would
hate like like if you can do it both in
your skill yeah and in how you will as a
person just like I made the video I
don't if you watch it honey
Empire yeah I want I care about both
yeah I care about both yeah I was skiing
coming in is like Oh is she a little bit
today turn but to urban or if she's
gonna fall state with clients or is she
gonna I'm useful boy I mean I'm the most
rogue of the whole bunch right I was but
must be a lot of ass kid just keep
comparing if I see a lot of how room
please like working here this is you
know like look I don't know I don't know
if it's the cliche I don't know how you
know pop swirl looks but to me like
definitely not to urban dead like to me
it doesn't matter what the culture what
makes this place great is no matter what
it is the skills both in people skills
and hard work will trump anything yeah
yeah definitely
I love yeah good good good keep it going
ping me if you ever need me yeah take
care
you're welcome
hi how are you Gary yeah
Sofia how are you so good to finally
meet such a pleasure how long have you
been here so I've been here for like a
month and a half I started interning our
position to be Sam yep yep it's been
terrible good good what makes me happy
yeah I've just been taking on projects
and getting involved with different
people and trying to carry out what
things stands for and yeah especially I
actually brought this because so I asked
everyone in the office to do a little
picture of something that like resonates
with them or that they love I scanned
all of them and I'm going to collaborate
all of the doodles and meet like a big
piece of art for the office I love it
awesome office so I brought this for you
to maybe doodle a second to do yes oh
well I'll doodle while we talk okay I've
got mine I've got a cup doodling
capabilities so tell me about yourself
where are you from I'm from the city New
York yeah New York City on your side and
then I also grew up in Israel is that
right yeah where tell deeper Jerusalem
how long she lived there for about five
years total and what more and what times
um what fourth grade she's a three yeah
every summer I worked on the key books
for two for two months that's cool so I
was born in Belarus yeah and I left in
78 when all the Jews left and so a lot
of my family with his real - nice and
everybody eventually made it to the US
by the mid 80s um but um but I get it
nice it's cool huh so Incept so in 78
there was something where I left Russia
through political asylum because Israel
in the US teamed up to get Jews out of
Soviet Russia yeah because it wasn't a
very good scene for Jews and so we
Russia so that's kind of my background
and so what else are you into like you
super art of it oh my god I almost wear
this I cannot believe you're wearing
those sneakers
I not only they're [ __ ] amazing I
actually started putting them on and
decided I wanted to go low top instead
of high top because I was lazy either we
literally literally almost wore the same
sneakers today also you had the low top
of the finest no I have that exact pair
but I was lazy this morning I pulled him
out and it takes me an extra second to
put those on versus low tops and I was
like [ __ ] that I don't know I don't have
a second hello nice to meet you person
oh yeah good to see you
no worries no worries so tell me about
your super school so I am I move to
yesterday back in April with no place to
live I just knew I had to be here I was
an advertising major there's a lot of
opportunity in Sarasota
honestly it's an old people town I know
it well so really yeah oh um yep so I
said all right you know what resins what
I want to do I need to go get my feet
wet for the earth industry so I was New
York City so I found out my suitcases
ical table from friends and friend for
about three and a half weeks good for
you um yeah I found a place to sublease
on the story of Queens cuz it was pretty
cheap and then I eventually got this job
I have to tell you the weirdest thing
about it all is that a week before I
don't even know if we here
I didn't know via where this was before
I got my interview but I saw a video
preaching tours and college events and
amazing thing you have this putter
winner to attack it babalons like wow
this guy's amazing this is inspirational
so I posted it on Facebook
a week later Alex purchase out I have my
interview meet Joe and Camilo and I am
ventually get the job and I looked at my
facebook timeline I really notice it
said Gary Vaynerchuk no company now
that's so awesome crazy that's so cool
yeah I'm glad here you know I didn't
move to New York to settle for a job I
you know move to to chase my dreams and
to work hard and so hopefully you don't
succeed and I for you I'll be there what
can I answer for you anything anything
you're curious about there's a lot more
coming yeah sure any insights you can
get already that's my god I know I mean
it's all gonna always be good yeah like
I don't know like like the video I said
like like if if you if you have true
heart and good intent and good stuff and
you're also a [ __ ] beast and want to
rip people's throats out of their bodies
you'll always win so you know how's it
going it's all pockets you know rats
kale some things are going phenomenal
some things are horseshit but net net
unbelievable and about to get way better
so communicate is the biggest thing I
would tell you don't get just pocketed
into your world and those mentors use
clawed use me I think of it as everybody
out there as governors and this is like
DC keep that in mind if you ever need it
I mean the vibes I'm getting it seems
like it's going really well so I'm not
but you never know right you can put on
Team Manager above uses you know there's
the thing I'm worried about for a guy
that fits your profile is there's always
that concern around meritocracy if
there's like raw talent how they handle
the patience game when people above them
around them aren't playing that same
game that's a tricky one but if you can
win it you win big yeah I spend my whole
life interacting with people there
not as strong as I am I mean that once
you could not calibrate that it all
[ __ ] flows a lot easier when you
[ __ ] eat the [ __ ] for twenty years
like I did to get to the point not as
fun early in the game but I'm telling
you that in case you ever want to have a
conversation about it thank you very
much everybody male ah here we go
you shut up so just with that here if
you spend 15 here you'd be 55 yeah hello
hi how are you okay you were so fired up
I was intrigued so hey we uh you know
just want to spend some time with you
guys and say hello and see what's up and
Kim and I were chatting we thought it'd
be a good idea to like get together
like we have in some other times and so
I guess you know in the limited time
that we have as I was thinking about
this meeting I think the first and
foremost thing is is a tricky one that
Ricky thing I want to start with and I
want to hedge it by saying it's a tricky
thing because I think you guys remember
with the all hands on I have a lot of
fear of the entertainment team the
creative team the Bud Light team I have
enormous fear of that however that's
just life I mean you know the only so
far communism can take you so so the you
know with that said and with it and with
it being very important and I would say
I want to be very transparent there's a
lot of people here that I hope I get to
interact with for the rest of my career
and yours that it's important to not let
it Trump anything that is the logo but
with that being said the first thing I
want to start with is thanking you from
the bottom of my heart of having
enormous ly strong DNA and the thing
that I probably care about the most when
push comes to shove which is this team
over the last forever and definitely
over this last year has performed at a
hustle level that is inspiring to me and
very honestly brings me vibes that I
want to like break all of you up and put
you in all different places so that you
can bring that to the table and so for
that I want to thank you and really it's
appreciated and it's very real - I
thought about something that was super
important to me there's so many people
in this room that I just don't spend any
time with and I don't I'm just you know
it's funny I'm look at hussein's and the
others that I've been here like that
Alex like I'm just never gonna win this
game
I'm just not gonna win this game you
know I'm just not I have to [ __ ] it's
kind of like the Jets I just have to
wrap my head around it it's not
happening but but um you know anything I
can do in this limited time together
right now to like you know look I'm a
very fond believer in the leaders of
this ecosystem but what if you're having
a problem with them like not super fun -
like like how do you have that talk if
you're struggling with your boss or your
boss's boss or your boss's boss one that
analogy that I'm gonna start using a lot
of Boehner is the United States and I
kind of view some of the things you'll
see structurally that I'm about to
announce and kind of what's in place
with me and Claud that I refer to or
James is you know I look at Chris and
Kim and who say I look at them as
governors and I look at myself as
Washington DC I I really genuinely want
you guys to know this and I don't know
if you know it I think some of you know
it but I'm gonna just pound it like I
just don't have any more vested
interests in Hussein Chris or Kim versus
Jody I just don't to me it's all the
same and so the quicker people
understand that the quicker they feel
safe the quicker we can have real
conversations the quicker I can address
[ __ ] you know you know obviously the the
video I sent last week versus in lieu
with the email I'm not going to be able
to defeat what happens outside these
four walls that creates an enormous
amount of cynicism fear negativity but I
will chip away at it and if I can get
one of you to feel more comfortable to
like stop by and say hello and there's
someone Katie I'm [ __ ] like I don't I
don't want I don't want to go
Katie I don't want to go for years in
between five minutes ATS so so so you
know what I mean
so now listen very frankly to some of
you like if shits cruising and it's
phenomenal great cuz I'll take the five
minutes back because there's 74,000
other fires but I want to continue to
pound to remind you especially when you
get in caught into such a tight-knit
ecosystem that like this is not
vaynermedia vaynermedia is different for
every person based on the people they
interact with
but the intent is very consistent and I
just have to continue to pound that and
then finally really I just kind of
thought what would be really smart for
5-10 minutes is maybe do a QA you know
I've been I've been talking a big game
of townhall QA for the whole company and
I've been miserably inefficient since I
haven't delivered on it and it's a ready
top of mind for like I have to crack
that nut because I think it will solve a
lot and so I'll banter for another two
minutes here while I get you to think
about how much courage or what question
you want to ask but um but as I stall
for that one minute I'm very very
thankful for you guys efforts I'm
excited there's a lot of good stuff
coming down the pipe a lot of a lot of
exciting stuff our brand within the
ecosystem of entertainment is very
strong and growing I'm getting a lot of
inquiries from studio owners and media
companies and networks and so I'm really
really proud of what's going on here and
I want to thank you guys for that I
think it'd be really smart for you to
clap for each other and look directly in
somebody look in somebody's face
I apologize for the cheesy nature of
that before do I [ __ ] love I love
[ __ ] clapping they you know an SVP
like there's a lot this is big this has
been a lot of time in the making this
was a lot of my off you know August by
myself how do I win in seventeen you're
like [ __ ] I haven't been able to
watch one play than anything one in ten
minutes I have to go speak at Columbia
but I'll see you Friday probably I mean
super punch line is I made a macro
decision predicated on my belief that
you wanted to go into CPG you overplayed
let's go hobbies outside
Bobby
one 301 that's my dorm room this is what
you have her this is what I plan I have
a second email with other stuff if you
don't want to go with this I think this
will be so Fox let's go and write have
it done right
the sign is in is the next one Peter's
gonna have it any minute this great new
home okay corners don't sorry we're
gonna price it right now or don't do
that
ya ready yep and how did you want me to
market the foxglove if there's any other
way did you owe me the title if you want
do you want
I definitely want to title it make sure
I do okay I can probably do that
tomorrow I'll go Wi-Fi I'm gonna catch
up that's when Miss Thursday that's
Thursday other whites coming in tomorrow
okay
signee is $10 cause searchers $19.99 one
store the SRP is 24 bucks mighty one
partner um it's 250 cases from up we
didn't really have anything yeah let's
go $24.99 $19.99 and let's go
1899 free shipping by the case for one
day only got it
where's the cornerstone P now you'll get
me about that bottle I need that you'll
rate that probably right huh
I'll probably make a video to what am I
here of do you rock Thursday night
Friday I'm here in the office Friday
right yeah oh then we have to do it
Friday okay we should always be 1 1 bar
class or some price less and free
shipping got it we had that for a little
bit okay
you know we're going
change
get help
make the change
no dad I wouldn't been doing that like
hey man oh I'm so sorry but there was
something interesting just happened did
you ask him would he invest in the
person who if he took the turn deal
which was the early deal right yeah well
the answer to the interesting part there
that was interesting is he wouldn't have
not known the other outcome like if they
took that first deal you just wouldn't
know
right so I think I think that that's
something that I'm always fascinated by
which is people are so crippled by
decisions there's just no way to know
what would have happened you know at the
time when you're making the decision a
lot so much of this is Monday morning
quarterbacking that I'm fascinated
so anyway nonetheless um yeah I've known
this man since I was fourteen fifteen
years old because my family had a liquor
store in Springfield New Jersey that I
started working at when I was 14 that I
later turned into something called Wine
Library and launched one of the first
three or four ecommerce wine businesses
in America called winelibrary.com back
in 1996 and your professor here was a
hardcore why nerd that knew way too much
about not wine for such a young dude and
I was a child but like that was my whole
life and what I cared about and I
I built my dad's business from a 3 to a
65 million dollar business but I did it
on on digital marketing innovation of
the time in 1997 I had an email
newsletter that had 91 percent open
rates because nobody was email marketing
and instead of sending catalogs from
sherry Lehman's or Zaki's I was getting
to customers first with the hottest
wines on this thing email I was trying
to send as many emails as possible 97
because I thought people would
eventually charge for it like it was
just like it seems such a great deal
launching a website email really I mean
you know it's funny it's like if
but but very honestly you know if we
start talking about VR we're going to
make a lot of assumptions right now that
are either going to play out or not play
out in a twenty thirty year window 1996
internet was a whole different [ __ ]
world and so I kept innovating bought
the word wine on you know they Google
AdWords came out for five cents a click
that was a good bet and no there for a
long time and just did a lot of smart
digital marketing things and then I did
it show on YouTube a couple months after
YouTube came out called Wine Library TV
where I sat in front of a camera and
drank four bottles of wine for 20
minutes and a lot of people watch that
and that's how I kind of hit the scene
in the tech world and then what happened
was YouTube sold for 1.7 billion dollars
and I was like [ __ ] I was right about
EECOM I was right about Google AdWords I
was right about you know cookie
retargeting banner ads I was right about
YouTube maybe this skill I have for
selling more you know Bergin Ian and
prio rack can be deployed against
something more financially interesting
so when I read the article about
YouTube's sale there was one article
that featured Ron Conway's angel
investor the investment and I said what
the [ __ ] an angel investor I googled
it and did you know within 20 minutes
decided I would be an angel investor and
went to South by Southwest
three months later became friends with
eff Williams and Blaine cook the
original CTO and I think your firm at
the time me and Kevin Rose bought up
Blaine's original stock at Twitter so
about a ton of Twitter real cheap I
didn't think of myself as an angel
investor I just thought that was a smart
decision because I thought Twitter would
be big then I went home from South I
made a loop well it did for me because I
sold my shares so I did good but came
home made a video I was making wine
videos came home made a video that said
Facebook should be worried about Twitter
there's a guy I've had a platform at the
time at Facebook that I didn't know by
the name of Dave Morin sent me an email
is like hey this video has gotten really
viral inside of Facebook would you come
out to Palo Alto and give a talk so came
to a room like this when put in front of
the whole company there's only 400
employees and talked about consumer
behavior and why I thought the world was
changing that caught Marc's attention we
run out to dinner that night in a week
late
I bought a lot of stock from his parents
and then somehow I got David Karp to
reopen the B round of tumblr out of by
the way stick with me here the B round
at a 14 million dollar valuation and I
made an investment into tumblr so the
first three things I invested in were
Twitter Facebook and Tumblr yeah I mean
it was it was when I was smart I was
making bets on things that I thought
would be successful I didn't think of
myself as an investor I got
progressively stupider after that but
because I started trying to be an
investor I literally went from being I'm
a businessman these are good businesses
this is good the market changed and this
is tumblr be around 2008 be around 14
million now every fake [ __ ]
entrepreneur running around this campus
wants 7 million 4 million for their
[ __ ] idea that they have no prayer
on because entrepreneurship is popular
and instead of going to Bain and
McKenzie they think they can start a
[ __ ] app that people are going to use
the brand equity around being an
entrepreneur today is stunning it is
stunning for me to in the world like I
can't believe how cool it is in real
life
to be an entrepreneur and that makes a
lot of young individuals gravitate
towards that is that but you but you're
suggesting overall that's worse than if
those young individuals went to work for
Goldman Sachs or McKinsey I am because
I'll tell you what we are not the world
is a better place even with the bad
ideas no I do not let me explain why the
biggest conversation that I'm fascinated
by is the suicide rate at Wharton last
year so we have in parallel a narrative
that anybody can do it and everybody's
entitled to win in entrepreneurship and
there's an underbelly in our world that
I'm concerned about and you know we talk
about this in a different panel this is
a big thing I mean like when you were
there are certain individuals who've
been winning in the first 20 years of
their life in a game that was fixed
before they played it and then they go
into the market and the market punches
them in the
mouths and they don't know how to react
and so yes I do think for the cliche
painter picture that I'm painting right
now there are certain individuals that I
just genuinely believe would have had a
better life being the number seven at
Facebook instead of the number one of
[ __ ] book or or or or making two hundred
thirty thousand a year on Wall Street or
consulting land at twenty nine years old
yes I think there's a lot of people that
will be better like I love
entrepreneurship the most but nothing
works when it's forced or off-balance
nothing you know I don't get the judge
who should I'm just excited to see how
it all plays out do you know what I mean
I mean who should who should do anything
in the world the people you know what I
love about this is there'll be plenty of
winners during this era
they'll just be a lot more losers you
know and so that's all just a timing
thing this is so classic this is every
market on everything always in forever
it's why I love brands so much this is
when brand takes over reality I know
that was a big statement so so I think a
lot of like so I grew out of my crew
grew out of the angel super angel dies
and gals that were successful in their
first internet business made some money
and we're getting had enough Twitter
followers let's get to the punchline to
attract unbelievable deal flow I made a
lot of I'm gonna I'm ate a lot I'm gonna
continue to make a lot of money from
that pocket but a lot of us shouldn't
necessarily be investors we may be
should keeping some investment behavior
but we should all really map ourselves
but yeah I think it's I think I think
all of this comes down to the supply and
demand of the skills and I think I just
think people are very attracted to this
world and I think if especially when I
sit in a class like this you know my I
try to reverse-engineer every situation
I'm in especially how do I bring value
if I could get one person in this room
to actually pay attention tonight go
home look in the mirror and try to start
deploying aggressive self-awareness it
could change the upside of their lives I
genuinely believe that I just hope they
don't work for Goldman Sachs
or they should I mean I really you know
or maybe they should work for their
family business I don't know but I know
that way too many people just go with
the flow I know how strong minded I am
and how easy that is for me to get
caught up and so I just think it's a
worthwhile conversation especially
because too many people make a decision
on the now not on when they're actually
playing it out doesn't really matter to
you if you go in this world today
matters what the impact is over a thirty
six to sixty month window in fact you
have to really quantify that looking at
data told you what happened
you need to deploy real intuition and
other kind of signs to what's going to
happen so you can make the decision for
you thank you thank you have a sorry I'm
late no it's great I appreciate it good
to see you hold on hi yes I missed you I
want to do a picture we're gonna get the
middle Souter I'm by the way oh thank
you for you I love when we talk yeah a
ton here yeah mine I really want to say
hey Jenny it's good to see you brother
you too
great to see you soon hey why don't meet
this guy
how are you married thanks for coming
tonight yes No
I got out of school today that's the
best part gonna use that any excuse
optimal women absolutely despise school
so and you can preach anything I can do
it out of that awesome finally I'm
convinced Eliot and ethic yep yep you
actually whether you know it or not
connected the two of us to seventy
something ask Gary B yep
how do you pick my question
yep I honestly didn't even know that
there was someone that age doing what I
was doing I did the Facebook version
when Elliot devs I had no idea there
were someone because obvious I'm not
working here behind yellow yep with no
idea yeah of course so to see a Lian Yu
yep Machiavellian tons of phone calls
next I'm helping him currently build his
Facebook love over you okay yeah I love
it keep jamming but yeah so I just
wanted to come here first of all let you
know that your content is I'm going to
look at when I'm going birth time myself
yep three information yep motivation yep
nana-chan yes very very few people
provide all four I appreciate I
appreciate this a very big compliment
ready go
bye guys thank you thank you that was
awesome highly appreciate thank you
headed back a home change into a suit
who charity event some friends and fam
and then uh maybe head out for a couple
more meetings good day fun meetings
grind design